I was never a pro-mandate but in the
beginning I thought the vaccine was a
miracle you know I was proud of American
industry for coming up with this thing
so soon and the first version of the
vaccine seemed seemed like the best one
because there was I believe still some
measure of protection protection against
the spread uh of covid and so that
particular vaccine worked fairly well
against that original version of covid
and it's just gone steadily downhill
since then and so now I've got some
serious questions about efficacy about
dangers yes side effects from the
vaccine but also what are we doing to
our immune systems and other other body
bodily systems when we take the vaccine
that won't prevent us from giving
getting coveted and then we get covet so
now you've had at least a double shock
to your immune system
foreign
your show every day are there moments of
uh of frustration or is it just pure
like you're just getting the information
in and you kind of comment on it and
talk to people or does it wear on you
ever because I I'm like sort of for the
most part I'm pretty much enjoying the
show and all that stuff but every now
and again like I was on as we're taping
this now I was on your show earlier
today and it's like this Kamala thing
with the communities of color and the
equity stuff it it really was getting to
me it really was like maybe that's a
little bit of the the new father thing
like I'm feeling this like need for the
Next Generation suddenly in a new way or
something but like these are just
horrible ideas and bad people
yes and these culture wars in particular
really upset me and the covid overreach
really upset me the longer it went down
the thing that made me the maddest I've
been in probably the past two years was
the the shaming of parents who wanted
the masks off their kids like you
haven't done your part you don't care
you know about society and the old
people and it's like we've done our part
our children have done our part this has
been an absolutely senseless exercise
what you're doing to these kids and
finally parents had to stand up and
basically raise the middle finger and
say it's on whether we're Democrats or
Republicans it's on we're showing up at
your school board meetings we're we're
going to rhetorically torture you until
you listen to us and you can call us
terrorists you can send the FBI in we
don't give a fig we're not going
anywhere I felt it so many parents felt
it and we won that battle that that's
that's why Glenn Younkin won in Virginia
and and it's why the Democrats almost
immediately abandoned those positions
they recognized they were all going to
suffer the same fate as young can or the
governor Phil Murphy of New Jersey who
only won by two or three points was
expected to win by 30. they got it and
those were reasons the reason those kids
don't have masks on their schools right
now and that it's because the parents
that stuff fires me up when when the
weak or the vulnerable or the smallest
Among Us can't fight for themselves and
the kid thing was really annoying he had
people like Randy Weingarten like
they're resilient they don't complain
they're little they don't know how to
give voice to this stuff like they're
not loud mouths like you or me we're
here for them Randy Weingarten is the
enemy I'm sorry but she is the enemy of
children and she has to be identified
and treated as such and frankly Dr fauci
is in exactly the same camp so I'm so
glad you just said that because that's
where I was gonna what do we do about
these people I am not one for jailing
our political opponents and I don't want
to throw them in gulags and all the
things that they probably want to do to
us but when you look at somebody like
Randy Weingarten who's now taking the
reverse of all the positions or claiming
that she took is taking the reverse of
all the positions she had for two years
and fauci who you know uh not wearing
masks at a baseball game while telling
us to wear masks all the stuff everyone
knows all this stuff what do we do with
these people like publicly what what
should happen over and over and over and
I really think this is one hopeful thing
about the Republicans taking the house
which we believe they will uh I mean it
would take a massive disaster between
now and the election day for the
Republicans to lose the house but
um they're going to investigate fauci
and I know he went out there and said
like I'll consider it if they play nice
you know I didn't I didn't appreciate
the way I was treated before and I would
expect to be tree you'll show up and
you'll sit down and you'll answer the
questions or you you will be found in
contempt of congress that's how this
works you don't get to say maybe I'll
come right that's what a subpoena is for
so we could get some real answers if the
GOP takes over the house and invest the
covet Origins and more maybe not more
importantly but equally importantly the
cover-up by our Public Health officials
what the hell went wrong at the CDC and
the NIH and how did they become such
huge Behemoth god-like institutions in
the eyes of the media and the Liberals
to where their quote science TM could
not be questioned because it's still
happening Dave I mean I I'm preparing
for a big interview that's going to hit
soon and I'm neck deep in this right now
the vaccines and the information about
the damage that the vaccines are doing
versus their efficacy is dark it's it's
not turning out the way even vaccine
proponents like yours truly wanted it to
why is it being buried why can't we talk
about it even journals like science and
nature and
um New England Journal of Medicine are
starting to release the studies showing
that there's a real risk in taking the
vaccine and then you get covid after
you've taken the vaccine these are dark
times they can take you to Dark Places
and there's not an acknowledgment by
people like fauci he still wants vaccine
mandates they refuse to acknowledge that
the vaccine doesn't stop the spread and
yet we're still imposing the mandates as
though they do and then endangering
people who get the vaccine who don't
need it who then will probably get
covered anyway because it doesn't
protect you from getting the
transmission so you're really messing
with your immune system in dangerous
ways they won't acknowledge it the only
answer is public accountability an
outcry wasn't it also amazing how it's
like we had this Federal mask mandate on
the planes and then one judge in Tampa
is like no no no more everyone takes the
masks off the next day and there's no
spike in kovid there's no sudden
Outbreak on a plane that's you know
taking it over to Europe or vice versa
and but we don't really like stop and
acknowledge that like boy they just the
week before fauci was like yeah we
should extend it on the planes yeah I
know God bless that judge and some
people even on the right some lawyers I
respect ripped her opinion and I was
like you know what it's a great opinion
I totally agree with it
um and it stood right now it stands and
we've been fine we've been fine I don't
think the masks are going to come back I
really don't except for in like really
crazy leftist cities maybe New York City
you know maybe La
um I don't think they're coming back
because people have seen with their
children how damaging that is you know
they I still see people in the New York
area riding around with a mask in the
car by themselves but I think for the
most part we're done doing it on a
mandatory basis for children the vaccine
mandate though it's still in a lot of
places I think you said before that you
were a vaccine proponent does that mean
that you're not a vaccine proponent now
yes it does I was never a pro mandate
but in the beginning I thought the
vaccine was a miracle you know I was
proud of American industry for coming up
with this thing so soon and the first
version of the vaccine seemed seemed
like the best one because there was I
believe still some measure of protection
protection against the spread uh of
covid and so that particular vaccine
worked fairly well against that original
version of covid and it's just gone
steadily downhill since then and so now
I've got some serious questions about
efficacy about dangers yes side effects
from the vaccine but also
what are we doing to our immune systems
and other other body bodily systems when
we take the vaccine that won't prevent
us from giving getting covered and then
we get coveted so now you've had at
least a double shock to your immune
system there are questions about what it
actually does if anything to DNA there
have been denials and so on but more and
more information is starting to come out
now as you would expect we're two years
into having the vaccines you can't trust
the American public health services they
they have only one Mission which is to
push more vaccines on us you have to
start getting your information from the
UK from Sweden some from Finland uh from
Israel like there are countries who are
taking honest looks at this sadly we're
not one of them
and by the way every country you just
mentioned I mean they're making mistakes
too right like even you can get your
information from pretty much everywhere
and even then it's like it's hard to
tell what's true but I don't trust the
people who never revise their opinions
after new data comes right right you
know and I mean seriously like there's
now like in in the UK you're not
supposed to they're not recommending the
vaccine they don't they won't give it
unless there's special circumstances to
kids under 12. here at our school
there's a mandate in place now it
doesn't kick in until you're 16 but
there are still school systems in the
country where you have to get it under
age 12 or you're expelled that's what's
happening in Washington DC they just had
to hold off on it because it was going
to lead to half of their population and
that's a black school population that
wasn't going to be able to go to school
so they cared about that right but
they're mandating it now for young
people when we really have no idea
whether it's actually going to lead to
increasing cardiac events for young
children myocarditis and Beyond I
featured friends of mine Dave on my show
friends of mine who I got to know at the
beach their 17 year old son died
suddenly of a heart attack of a heart
incident caused by myocarditis he wasn't
sick he had coveted and he had the
vaccine and the family doesn't know they
don't know what led to his death but he
was perfectly able-bodied five months
after he got the vaccine and some about
a year after he had coveted he died of
myocarditis there's just been too many
incidents like that and if you look at
the rise in cardiac events amongst young
people now
um it's disturbingly high and it seems
to follow you if you look at the graphs
in these magazines I've seen something
like far left or far right magazines
um they follow spikes in the vaccination
rate they don't follow spikes in covid
like the outbreak of Omicron it's not
like all the cardiac deaths were
happening then amongst the young people
they have been following the increases
in vaccination rates country to Country
so
look all of that disturbs me and gives
me pause and as a journalist says I want
to know more I want to know more and I
know where not to look I will not look
at Rachelle wolenski or Anthony fauci or
anybody at the NIH or the who I mean
fauci just gave another Grant to Peter
dazick's group ecohealth Alliance
another 600 plus thousand it's going to
go up to 3.3 million to do more bat
coronavirus research in China these are
the people that we're looking to for
answers no so I'm still looking for the
perfect advisor but I know that they're
overseas if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about the media instead of non-stop
yelling check out our media playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out the full
episode playlist they're both right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell